hey guys i'm kelly and i'm a culinary
producer at tasty and i love apple pie
apple pie is the best of both worlds it
pairs that crispy buttery flaky crust
with baked spiced apples seasoned with
all those warming delicious spices but i
understand that sometimes it can seem
intimidating so today i'm going to make
a six minute a 60 minute and a six hour
apple pie to show you that you can make
this delicious dessert no matter how
much time you have all right let's get
into it
first up is our six minute apple crisp
it's really great if you're living in a
dorm or maybe you're having that late
night apple pie craving and you just
need it now so first thing we'll do is
just chop this apple
we're gonna cut nice thin slices
since we're cooking it in the microwave
we need to cut it pretty small so it
cooks quickly and evenly
we're using a honeycrisp because it's my
favorite type of apple but you can use
you know whatever you like whatever your
favorite is there's a lot of good
varieties out there okay so now all of
our apples are diced and we're gonna put
them in our mug our next step is to just
add a tablespoon of water to our apples
and all that's gonna do is help steam
them and soften them while they cook the
first time so let's go add this to the
microwave for one minute okay so now our
apples have softened so i'm gonna add a
little bit of cinnamon brown sugar and a
little bit of flour just a teaspoon to
thicken up the base so it's not like a
watery mess and of course a little pinch
of salt so we're just gonna stir this
together i love seeing the like speckled
little cinnamon bits i think it's so
pretty next we're going to make the
crumble so we have some oats some flour
more brown sugar more cinnamon we'll
just whisk that together with our fork
and then the last thing we're going to
add
oh besides more salt sorry
is some softened room temperature butter
we're just gonna mix this together until
it forms like nice chunks spread these
oats in a nice even layer covering most
of the apples put this in the microwave
for three to four minutes until the top
is golden brown and crispy all right
it's out of the microwave it's looking
awesome you can tell all those juices
thickened up just from that little bit
of flour and i cannot wait to dig in but
first
a little garnish some whipped cream
and lastly a little cinnamon i mean i
think this is so cute i actually think
it's really pretty it looks awesome
let's try it
the apples are tender they're full of
that cinnamon flavor and the crisp is so
crunchy honestly this is really good but
if you have a little bit more time and
you want to make pie for more than just
yourself let me show you how to make
this 60 minute apple pie
so what i love about this recipe is it's
more close to your traditional apple pie
but it is not going to take up your
whole day to make it so first thing
we're going to do is peel our apples
make sure you have a good peeler and
your work will go much quicker so we're
using two types of apples today we're
using golden delicious and gala apples
gala i don't know we're using those
because they're a softer type of apple
and they'll cook quicker in our pie and
save us time and then we're going to
slice them a little bit thinner than you
normally would
so in culinary school we had to practice
our knife cuts on potatoes and carrots
so i used to sneak potatoes in my bag
and take them home so i could practice
because i wanted to do the best
so that's all of our apples so now we're
just gonna add brown sugar lemon juice
so they don't brown corn starch to
thicken it cinnamon nutmeg
and salt you never bake without salt so
we're going to toss this all together
and we're going to let it sit while we
assemble our pie crust we have a
store-bought pie crust we're just going
to roll it out a little bit
wider than the width of our pan and
that's because we want to create those
really fun edges and we need a little
bit of length on the end to get that so
this is looking wide enough to me what
i'm gonna do is roll it up brushing off
any extra flour along the way
and then bring your pie pan to you
and gently roll it in
and magically it's in your pan press it
down on the bottom
so it reaches the edges brush off any
excess flour
okay so now we're going to add all of
those apples we're just going to put
this in the fridge while we make our top
crust so for my top crust i rolled it
out to about a 12 inch circle and what
i'm going to do is cut it in strips to
make a pretty lattice shape on top so it
kind of upgrades our pie so nobody has
to know that we use store-bought dough
so we have to make six one-inch strips
and eight half-inch strips
take your longest piece first and place
it in the middle and this is going to be
your guide so we'll lay two of the half
inch strips in between each of the
one-inch strips pull back each of the
one-inch strips and gently place another
one-inch strip horizontally across then
fold the one in strips back down over so
you're going to keep doing that process
alternating between the thick pieces and
the thin pieces until you get that
beautiful lattice design so now we're
going to do the edge we're going to do
something kind of different and roll it
inward tucking all those little bits in
so nobody has to see those jagged edges
we're going to start the crimping
process so use your knuckle to like dig
in and then use your thumb and index
finger to push back and just keep going
around
so now what we want to do is just brush
off any of that excess flour because
when we add the egg wash next we really
want that to stick to the crust and now
our last step is to add some raw sugar
on top just to give it another little
crunch so we're going to bake this in a
425 degree oven for 40 minutes covering
halfway through until the crust is
golden brown and the juices are bubbling
let's go
all right she's out of the oven she's
golden she's glossy from the egg white
i'm really excited to try it let's dig
in
i like don't want to cut her because
she's too pretty
um
for a 60 minute pie that came together
with just a little bit of effort the
filling has tons of cinnamon flavor the
crust is super crunchy and that raw
sugar just gives it that little bit of
edge but if you have more time and you
really want to impress your friends and
family stick with me for this next
recipe
now i'm going to show you how to make my
six hour salted caramel deep dish apple
pie so first what we're going to do is
just season our flour then we're going
to add in our cold butter i cut this in
about half inch cubes and i actually
popped it in the freezer for about 15
minutes just so it's really cold and
firm so what i like to do is like make
sure each of the pieces is coated in
flour before i start smashing them toss
it onto the next one also i find this
therapeutic like i can just zone out the
kids yelling at me i can just zone out
and just keep doing my dough okay so
that is looking awesome the next step is
to add ice water a tablespoon at a time
so i like to toss it up in the air like
this just to incorporate that water and
then add a little bit more so we're
using ice cold water because we don't
want to melt that butter and you know
that there's enough water in it when you
press together and it holds together so
now that this is shaggy looking i'm
going to transfer it on the table
and finish bringing it all together i'm
going to wrap them in plastic and just
pop them in the fridge for about an hour
to let the gluten relax while that's
happening we'll make our filling so for
this filling we're doing something a
little bit different this time we're
gonna par cook the apples before they go
in the oven to bake so to start we have
two tablespoons of unsalted butter
melting we have a big bowl of apples
i'm gonna add them right in
we have the juice of one lemon brown
sugar salt of course so this is pumpkin
pie spice and you might be saying kelly
what the hell are you doing but listen
to me it has cinnamon it has nutmeg
ginger cardamom so we're adding a bunch
of that okay and you might think i'm
crazy again but i'm adding a little bit
of vanilla vanilla isn't something you
would traditionally find in apple pie
but martha stewart does it so i'm doing
it okay so
stir stir we want to cook it until the
sugar is dissolved so we have a little
bit of corn starch and i'm just going to
add some water to make a slurry and what
this does is just
incorporates the corn starch
without lumps so crank the heat up and
let it come to a boil and then once it's
thick we can set it aside and move to
the next step so since this is an epic
apple pie we're gonna add even more
apple flavor by reducing some apple
cider i learned this trick from a pastry
chef where you reduce down cider until
it's the consistency of like maple syrup
it's looking great i'm gonna let it cool
and then we will go assemble our pie so
i got my dough here it's been chilling
for an hour now i'm just gonna roll it
out until it's about a quarter of an
inch thick all right so this is rolled
out
i'm gonna do the same technique
roll it back on the pin and then roll it
back in
press it down we're gonna add in all of
those apples so i'm gonna pour over that
cooled apple cider that i reduced down
this is our secret ingredient put this
in the fridge while i roll out the top
crust all right so i rolled out my top
crust and now i'm going to add it on top
and then we'll finish assembling press
around the sides to make sure all of the
edges are
sealed together and we're going to take
a pair of scissors and just kind of
clean up any long edges i'm going to
tuck it under this time now we're going
to do the same technique as before with
the crimping we're just going to do them
a little bigger so they're a little more
exaggerated brush it with some egg wash
now we're going to cut some slits and
what this does is help the steam release
as it's cooking
so you don't end up with a soggy top put
this in the freezer for 20 minutes to
harden back up and then we'll put in the
oven for 80 to 90 minutes until these
juices are bubbling and thick so the
apple pie is in the oven it smells great
i cannot wait but to make it even more
epic we're gonna add a thick gooey
caramel sauce on top first we're
starting with sugar and water to make it
even more foolproof i'm going to add a
little bit of corn syrup it helps
prevent crystallization
and it will also keep that really glossy
shine that we want for the top of our
pie now that everything is in the pot
you're gonna bring it to a low boil and
cook it until it turns a light copper
color so i say caramel
some people might say caramel
caramel
wait what am i saying caramel caramel
like it sounds very blunt to me caramel
caramel caramel caramel
so this looks perfect it's like the
color of a copper penny we're going to
turn off the heat and add all the heavy
cream it's going to boil up so don't be
scared keep stirring until all the cream
is incorporated i'm just gonna let it
cool and then we'll top our pie with it
all right guys it is out of the oven
it's beautiful the last step is to pour
this delicious caramel sauce over the
top we're just gonna let it drip down
the sides oh my god it's so thick it's
glossy from that corn syrup the last
step is these candied pecans it is
finished it is smile high the sauce is
dripping off i cannot wait to try this
that is some serious pie the crust is
the best part like i'm a sucker for
crispy crust and this is like it's
buttery i could just eat the crust and
the caramel sauce alright well that is
it for us today we have made a six
minute a 60 minute and a six hour apple
pie i hope you guys make them and love
them as much as i do leave a comment
below and let us know what you think and
just remember there is always time for
apple pie
oh yes
[Music]
you